Oh it seems so exciting
I can talk to anyone
Just begin the game and launch into the fun.
But 15 perverts later, I still haven't had the chance
to talk to anyone but that giant guy in women underpants
It's the kind of instant judgment that I fear in the real world
Where it only takes a moment to realize you're not a girl.
And they click on "next" the game is over
and, yes, I've lost again.
But I keep on tryin' anyway because some day soon I'll win.
And I try to pour my heart out, but they keep clickin' "next."
'Cause I'm havin' a bad day on Chat Roulette.
Oh, I'm havin' a bad day on Chat Roulette.
*Boy starts playing bells*
And suddenly this cute girl, she pops up on my screen.
She's like the answer to my prayers
The woman of my dreams.
Yes, she pauses on my face.  And I think she could be mine.
I say, "Hello."  She smiles, I've got my chance.
And then she hits F9.
And then, in her place, is a group of rowdy British teens.
Followed by a person who does not wish to be seen.
And then a guy with awesome abs who won't put on his shirt.
And then, of course, a very, very long string of perverts.
And I try to pour my heart out, but they keep clickin' "next."
'Cause I'm havin' a bad day on Chat Roulette.
Oh, I'm havin' a bad day on Chat Roulette.
The pretty girls are busy having pleasant conversations
With guys who've been nexting for hours.
Oh, I really should eliminate all my expectations.
I should also probably take a shower.
But then this guy comes on and he sees me playin'
and he understands everything I'm sayin'
and he pulls down his guitar and he plays along.
*Man plays guitar*
*Man keeps playing*
(BOTH): And we try to pour our hearts out
(BOTH): But they keep clickin' next.
(BOTH): We're havin' a bad day on Chat Roulette.
Yes, we're havin' a bad day on Chat Roulette.
*Both stop playing*
(HANK): Just to be clear, because the internet is what it is, unfortunately,
Chat Roulette is a place for adults.
And I'm not gonna be on Chat Roulette
So don't go there lookin' for me.
Because you won't find me.
You'll find things that...no one wants to see.
Nonetheless, I hope that you enjoyed it.
Thank you so much to Tom Milsom, Kristina Horner, and Luke Conard.
And, of course, thank you to all the Nerdfighters who submitted clips of themselves looking bored
when I asked Twitter for those videos.
You should all take this as an invitation:
When you follow me on Twitter, sometimes you get to be in my music videos.
Kristina and Luke, who are in that video have a band,
They're called "ALL CAPS."
They have an album that just came out, there's a link to it in the sidebar.
*Weird noises*
And I'm also gonna put up some links to a couple music videos I did from that album,
So that you can enjoy them.
John, I will see you on Friday.
*Ending music*